bonjour à tous merci d'être sur notre
antenne et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo bonjour michaëlle jean piat et
nous sommes ensemble pour 45 minutes le
temps de faire le tour de l'actualité
politique de la semaine on va voir et
des frondeurs qui redonne de la voix au
sein de la majorité il lance aujourd'hui
l'appel des sens pour amender le pacte
de responsabilité de manuel valls il
réclame plus de pouvoir d'achat et des
aides ciblées pour les entreprises ils
veulent que la gauche acceptent de se
remettre en cause la réforme ferroviaire
objet de la colère des cheminots
résultats des grèves dans toute la
france un mouvement lancé avant même
l'examen à l'assemblée du projet de loi
qui vise notamment à fusionner la sncf
et réseau ferré de france et puis bien
sûr on prendra la direction de rio au
brésil pour le coup d'envoi du mondial
de foot événement sportif planétaire qui
se tient aussi sur fond de crise et de
contestation sociale on en parle à la
fin de cette émission c'est le plus de
l'hebdo est avec nous pour commenter
toute cette actualité père laurent
bonjour bonjour secrétaire nationale du
parti communiste français
vous êtes aussi sénateur de paris vous
connaissez la tradition de cette
émission on va évidemment développer
toute cette actualité mais d'abord on va
laisser les parlementaires dresser votre
portrait les écoutes et aux commandes
juste après
le gauche
intelligent et utile
je pense qu'il pâtit sans doute de cette
image un peu d'apparatchiks
formé
au biberon
du parti communiste et la souffert je
pense aussi de la comparaison de
l'affrontement avec jean luc mélenchon
moi je respecte les communistes ils font
partie de notre histoire nos paysages
voilà je les respecte et je regrette
avait peur que la politique
gouvernementale qu'on mène aujourd'hui
conduisent à
un schisme durable moi je respecte les
gens qui ont des convictions et pierre
laurent a des convictions dont je le
respecte je suis quand même étonné un
tout petit peu
de le voir pas très révolutionnaire
voilà je le trouve très raisonnable trop
raisonnable les respectables de la
mesure où c'est un militant convaincu
sincère qui défend des idées archaïques
qui n'ont plus rien à voir avec
l'organisation de nos sociétés mais je
respecte la sincérité et l'engagement de
l'homme je lui reconnaît honnêtement une
vraie sincérité
un discours franc et direct et je lui
reconnais très volontiers même si je ne
partage pas ses points de vue une bonne
foi et c'est un homme pour moi
respectable en perdront dans l'ensemble
c'est plus que positif mais raisonnable
trop raisonnable apparatchiks ça vous
choque un peu
ouattara chicks ses vieilles ancienne
qu'on nous répète et qui a pas beaucoup
de réussite ya pas beaucoup de réalités
n'ont jamais utile j'essaye d'être utile
il ya des députés qui l'a dit c'est très
important et le problème n'est pas de
tenir seulement des des grands discours
sans lendemain j'ai envie d'être utile
aux peuples surtout dans un moment qui
est un moment de crise très grave et les
gens attendent des changements concrets
mais quand un type bien laurent
maintenant de l'associé toujours à jean
luc mélenchon
quand est-ce que ça va se terminer
finalement question très simple le score
des européennes prouve qu'aujourd'hui
mais plus besoin de pied de
non je crois que le front de gauche est
très utile on a beaucoup réduit lé front
gauche mais ça c'est c'est pas abus à
jean luc mélenchon c'est dû à la
présidentialisation de la vie politique
qui veut toujours résumé tout à une
seule personne un seul homme une seule
femme et moi je ne partage pas gelé
toujours dit cette conception de la
politique donc le front de gauche est
une construction qui reste extrêmement
utile et qui doit s'élargir évidemment
au dialogue avec beaucoup d'écologie
cette socialiste je crois qu'on va en
parler qui ne se reconnaissent pas en ce
moment dans la politique gouvernementale
qu'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui pour
que le peuple vous entendez n'aille pas
vers d'autres partis pourquoi n'êtes
vous pas sont paralysés au dit non mais
écoutez y en a beaucoup qui nous qu avec
lesquels on travaille hier j'étais dans
la manifestation des cheminots
j étais d'ailleurs les gt oui oui mais
quand on est sur le terrain on
s'aperçoit qu'à beaucoup de gens qui
entendent ce qu'on dit peut-être encore
blue tilt de notre capacité à eux et à
nous ensemble collectivement à imposer
des solutions parce que ce d'outils
taraude le peuple français mais nous
travaillons et je pense que nous sommes
capable de déverrouiller la situation
assez vite alors on reste à gauche cette
semaine les frondeurs père laurent où
donner de la voix
il avait déjà plaidé début avril pour un
contrat de majorité avec le gouvernement
ce sont les frondeurs comme on les
surnomme il critique maintenant le
budget rectificatif et exige que la
gauche se remettent en cause après la
défaite la lourde défaite aux élections
européennes françois moulin ils ne
désarment pas ces députés socialistes
frondeurs compte bien peser sur le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
présenté ce mercredi en conseil des
ministres le groupe a dévoilé lundi des
propositions rassemblées dans ce
document notamment les 41 milliards de
baisses d'impôts prévues pour les
entreprises qu'ils veulent voir repensé
on garde 20 milliards sur les
entreprises en ciblant sur celles qui en
ont vraiment besoin les entreprises
industrielles qui s'engage à créer des
emplois et on remet 20 milliards dans le
soutien notamment du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages mais on va pas se situer dans
une logique de demander la permission de
pouce et puis si on n'est pas entendus
et bas comme d'habitude on est déçu et
on s'arrête là non on a des propositions
on va les traduire sous la forme
d'amendements et ses amendements va les
défendre autre idée que le collectif
compte bien faire inscrire dans la loi
l'instauration d'une csg progressive
le ministre de l'économie qui n'est pas
hostile à cette idée a pourtant rappelé
que le projet de loi prévoit y ait déjà
un coup de pouce aux foyers modestes
notre politique c'est aussi de soutenir
le pouvoir d'achat des plus humbles des
français ce sont vous l'avez dit plus
d'un million 800 mille contribuables
foyers qui vont sortir de l'impôt sur le
revenu 1 milliards de baisses d'impôts
pour les plus modestes au sein du groupe
ps les ténors de la ligue majoritaires
n'ont guère apprécié que la contestation
ym sur l'unité du parti c'est
quelquefois épuisants mois je vais faire
en sorte que le débat ait lieu mais
voilà serait quand même mieux d'essayer
d'avancer de montrer de la cohérence de
l'unité donne pas toujours être en
marche arrière une majorité d'autant
plus agacé que les députés frondeurs ont
reçu l'appui des communistes et des
écologistes c'est une contribution au
débat de socialistes et qui est bienvenu
puisque comme on le voit le la politique
qui est menée aujourd'hui n'est pas
suivi par les français le projet de loi
sera discuté à partir du 23 juin à
l'assemblée entre le gouvernement et sa
majorité le bras de fer reprend en avril
dernier les frondeurs avait menacé de ne
pas voter le programme de stabilité
budgétaire et avait tenu bon alors
visiblement les communistes on a entendu
soutiennent l'action de ces frondeurs
est ce qu'il ya des choses à construire
avec une nouvelle alliance à la gauche
de la gauche et de mon nos propositions
vont dans le domaine fiscal plus loin
que les leurs mais il ya effectivement
des passerelles à construire et si déjà
on peut avec eux remettre en cause une
partie des exonérations de cotisations
sociales dont on sait qu'elles ne vont
servir à rien pour résoudre le problème
du chômage qu'elles vont uniquement
alimenté des
ddd logique de rentabilité d'entreprise
sans aucun résultat pour le payer pour
les français si on peut ensemble faire
ce pas là nous le ferons et je pense que
global vous avez des discussions avec
eux où ils sont prêts à voir raison les
amendements communs mais proposeront
leurs amendements nous proposerons les
leurs mais sicile quoi s'ils peuvent
converger et si nous pouvons apporter
des modifications sensibles ensemble
avec les écologistes avec des
socialistes et avec les députés du front
gauche évidemment nous le ferons et plus
globalisé qu'indique l'occasion de toute
façon je pense que maintenant ce qui est
à l'ordre du jour pour toute l'année qui
vient c'est de construire le
rapprochement de l'ensemble de ceux qui
à gauche ne se reconnaissent pas dans la
politique gouvernementale cette
politique elle va dans le mur elle ne
réussit pas en termes de résultats elle
fait du mal au pays elle n'interrompt
pas l'hémorragie industrielle et elle
fait beaucoup de mal aux français parce
qu'elles développent les inégalités
sociales et elle est désavoué par le
pays et parce qu'ils ont voulu le
changement on va quand même pas
continuer la nouvelle gauche oui il faut
reconstruire un projet de gauche qui
n'est pas le projet gouvernemental au
lion manifestement ne veut rien
d'écouter le pays lui dit a plu à 10
dans les élections je ne veux pas de
cette politique et lui il dit on en
rajoute dans la même direction et on
continue et bien il y a maintenant on le
voit bien une très grande majorité de
gens à gauche qui dit stop vous avez
vous un clé jean luc mélenchon c'est un
allié tu as un problème le parti vrai il
fait partie qui sont maintenant nous
avons créé le front de gauche ensemble
il y a quatre ans parce que justement
nous nous avions la crainte que on
s'engage dans la voie de dans l'impasse
dans laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui
donc nous avons essayé d'alerter nous
avons réveillé des forces pour cela mais
maintenant ces forces elles ne suffisent
pas donc nous devons travailler avec des
forces plus large et moi je me suis
rendu dans une réunion de socialistes
qui critiquent cette politique
samedi dernier j'y vais encore samedi
soir à l'invitation d'autres socialistes
dans une autre réunion je serai partout
où des forces de gauche ont envie de
discuter avec les socialistes mais je
peux mais j'ai toujours parlé avec des
socialistes et actuel avait dit mais je
dis à ceux qui soutiennent la politique
gouvernementale vous aller dans le mur
vous emmener la france dans le mur et
personne ne se reconnaît dans cette voie
là donc il faut arrêter et puisque la
direction du parti socialiste s'accroche
pour le moment au président de la
république je dis à tous ceux qui ne
veulent pas suivre cette voie de l'échec
travaillons ensemble et il faut que
cette année soit une année de dialogue
de construction d'un autre en projet à
gauche puisqu'on parle de fronde va
parler d'une autre point de cette loi
qui touche aussi les parlementaires sur
le projet de réforme territoriale qui
femme est examiné au sénat manuel valls
est venu devant le groupe socialiste
pour essayer de désamorcer un petit peu
la crise on voit tous avec mounir souci
après le temps des annonces celui des
explications manuel valls était devant
les sénateurs pour préciser les contours
de la réforme territoriale un moment
attendu par les élus à la recherche de
précisions nous sommes exigeants
vigilance et exilant et exigeons que
sais je pense les deux mots qui
caractérisent à l'heure actuelle le
travail le travail du sénat plutôt que
déduire la réticence le frein ne pas
vouloir faire ne pas vouloir voir la
visite avait un objectif rassurer sa
majorité autour d'un texte qui a peu de
chance d'être adopté au sénat le premier
c'est très clair il sera très à l'écouté
de ce que vont proposer les
parlementaires et en particulier les
sénateurs nous qui avons cette charge de
l'organisation des territoires c'est
notre adn la loi devrait avoir un
parcours compliqué au sénat l'opposition
qui dénonce un amateurisme de la part du
gouvernement prépare la riposte et va
tout faire pour rétablir les principes
défendus dans la réforme du conseiller
territorial voté sous nicolas sarkozy
est abandonné par françois hollande nous
on ne va pas faire de l'opposition on va
leur dire écoutez ce qu'on avait proposé
était bien vous avez fait de la poésie
de l'opposition vous l'avez détruits et
bien maintenant on va le reconstruire
ensemble donc on va proposer des
amendements pour faire en sorte de
reconstruire quelque chose qui ne soit
pas bancal le texte serait examiné en
premier au sénat début juillet et il est
déjà promis un détricotage dans les
règles de l'art alors texte 8 et 9
juillet au sénat dans l'état actuel de
votre réflexion que fait le groupe
communiste au sénat
nous allons demander des changements
profonds de ce texte parce que ça ne ça
ne va pas bon je passe sur les
incohérences qui font que depuis
maintenant un an et demi on fait tout et
n'importe quoi sur cette réforme en
annonçant un jour une chose et le
lendemain son contraire comme l'assurent
la suppression des départements où la
suppression de la clause de compétence
générale
d'accord elle est sur la table mais avec
avec une contestation extrêmement forte
dans le pays dont les élus locaux et il
ya des choses très graves dans cette loi
d'abord donc il faut continuer à
expliquer pourquoi cette c'est une
impasse par exemple on nous dit on va
supprimer à simplifier
le millefeuille soi-disant le prétendu
millefeuille avec en vérité en vérité on
va se retrouver avec des choses encore
plus opaque encore plus compliqué
éloigner encore davantage des citoyens
et on va mettre en cause le tissu le
tissu de proximité le tissu démocratique
on n'a toujours pas compris entre les
communes qui par ailleurs vont être un
peu vidés de leur contenu et des énormes
région où étaient les échelons
intermédiaires qui permettait de piloter
les politiques sociales du pays donc
tout ça n'est pas clair du tout ça ne la
lève pardon elle passera pas l'étape du
sénat ça va voter bah écoutez là pour le
moment je vois pas où est la majorité
pour 7 pour cette réforme en l'état mais
nous nous ne sommes pas là pour pour
détruire nous nous avons toujours
avancer des propositions
à l'opposé de celles qui sont à chaque
fois mis sur la table le problème c'est
dans ce domaine comme dans celui dont on
parlait tout à l'heure est-ce qu'on
laisse au parlement est-ce qu'on laisse
au parlement la possibilité de légiférer
vraiment et même si les i aujourd'hui
les parlementaires rondeau
verra s'il le fait parce que pour le
moment depuis depuis le début de la
présidence de françois hollande
malheureusement comme c'était déjà le
cas avant c'est l'elysée qui tranchent
toutes les questions et on demande aux
parlementaires de la majorité de
d'appliquer la discipline
eh bien ça ne marchera pas d'accord sur
la nécessité de faire une réforme parce
que tous ces échelons territoriaux ça
coûte quand même cher et tout le monde
doit le problème il faut une réforme
mais pas mais pas parce qu'on a trop
d'échelons ça n'est pas vrai et
d'ailleurs les économies qu'ils vont
être générée par sa personne n'est
capable de l'est de les chiffrer on nous
explique par exemple qu'il ya trop
d'élus comment ça il ya trop d'élus et
on va faire d énormes région par exemple
on nous dit avec 150 élus il faut voir
ce que ça ait 150 élus dans des régions
de 2,5 millions 2,5 millions d'habitants
eh bien ça veut dire un éloignement
considérable entre les citoyens et leurs
élus pour le départ
au
sénat alors il y avait aussi de
l'actualité à droite cette semaine avec
un bureau politique très attendu à l'ump
le parti s'est réuni il a confirmé le
trio qui assure l'intérim du parti
l'intendance revient à luc chatel
nouvelle secrétaire général de l'ump
écoutez alain juppé et jean pierre
raffarin à la sortie de la réunion
c'était mardi c'est très important
d'avoir cette unanimité j'avais dis moi
même qu'il fallait d'un consensus ici
parce que les conventions des périodes
difficiles et seule une décision aussi
large que possible une alim vous permet
maintenant de repartir de l'avant c'est
un politique fort de rassemblement après
une crise très grave on est rassemblée
sur une volonté de donner la parole aux
mi temps avec un congrès alors les
affaires ne vont pas bien visiblement
l'ump ce que le parti communiste que
vous représentez a intérêt à avoir un
grand parti d'opposition dans un tel
état c'est une démo soit un gros partis
politiques dont la crise à cause
d'affaires financières pas très clair
parce que on est dans cette situation à
l'ump parce que la direction a failli
sur la gestion financière c'est quand
même pas très réjouissant pour la
démocratie moi je préfère des partis qui
sont transparents plutôt que des partis
qui gèrent leurs affaires financières
comme on le fait à l'ump bon on voit
bien que il ya une bataille de
leadership qui fait rage qui fait rage
depuis depuis la défaite de l'élection
présidentielle
il ça c'est certain ça continue
manifestement je ne sais pas comment ça
se terminera par ailleurs en par
ailleurs ça doit pas faire oublier que
malheureusement ces gens savent aussi se
rassembler à chaque fois qu'il s'agit de
voter un recul des droits sociaux à
chaque fois qu'il faut appuyer les
revendications du medef à chaque fois
qu'il faut demander de ne pas bouger de
la route ultra libérale européenne là
ils savent tous se rassembler sarkozy ça
vous fait peur ça vous inquiète
écoutez moi j'ai combattu nicolas
sarkozy c'est pas moi qui vais souhaiter
son retour en politique ceci étant dit
je ne pense pas que mon avis le moindre
poids dans les vestiaires la traque vous
écouter mais je pense que le pays n'a
absolument pas besoin du retour
politique de nicolas sarkozy
alors passez au budget examiné en
conseil des ministres mercredi
cinq cent mille ménages de
supplémentaires seront concernés par les
baisses vert pour 2014 michel sapin a
présenté le projet de loi de finances
correctif pour 2014 et en conseil des
ministres sa crime et nos moeurs
réduire les dépenses tout en baissant
les impôts mais sans creuser le déficit
voilà le casse tête que doit résoudre le
gouvernement dans son collectif
budgétaire de 2014 le gouvernement
annonce des allègements fiscaux à
hauteur de 1,1 milliard d'euros pour les
ménages modestes un geste fiscal qui
devrait réduire les impôts de 3,7
millions de ménages dont 1,9 million
sortiront de l'impôt une mesure qui
s'appliquera sur les revenus de 2013
donc dès la rentrée ce gouvernement une
autre idée de la justice fiscale il
entend travailler sur les contribuables
les plus modestes pour mettre en oeuvre
ce que dit notre constitution c'est à
dire que l'impôt doit être recyclé en
cas passés en tenant compte de la
capacité contributive
autre volet de ce plfr les efforts
d'économies réalisés par l'état 1,6
milliards dès cette année sous forme
d'annulations de crédit au ministère et
2,1 milliards d'euros d'économies dans
le cadre du projet de loi de finances
rectificatif pour la sécurité sociale
présenté la semaine prochaine au total
le gouvernement vise 4 milliards
d'économies supplémentaires
ils s'ajouteront aux 15 milliards déjà
prévus à l'automne ce matin c'était en
quelque sorte l'acte 1 de la mise en
oeuvre du pacte de responsabilité
nous sommes déterminés la compétitivité
pour les entreprises
la diminution des déficits et le
financement de l'ensemble par des
économies parce que les augmentations
d'impôts comme vous avez pu le faire
c'est fini il reste maintenant aux
gouvernements à convaincre la gauche du
ps lorsque l'on fait la somme des
mesures de hausse d'impôts qui ont déjà
été votées et qui vont continuer d'être
mises en oeuvre
et le gel des prestations sociales on
voit qu'au total malgré ces efforts qui
sont annoncés sur l'ensemble des ménages
leaf à l'effort global est assez minime
ces députés frondeurs entend bien
influer sur le texte grâce à de nombreux
amendements son examen débutera dans
l'hémicycle le 23 juin alors il ya
beaucoup de chiffres dans ce projet de
budget rectificatif on va essayer de les
comprendre tout de suite c'est le zoom
avec nos jean louis gombeaud bonjour
notre spécialiste notre éditorialiste
économique alors le gouvernement
présente ce projet de loi comme une
bonne nouvelle beaucoup de cadeaux mais
avec quoi sont-ils financer ces cadeaux
sur les déficits alors c'est une bonne
nouvelle en partie en tout cas pour les
contribuables effectivement parce que ça
n'a lui pas exactement de l'ensemble des
hausses d'impôts qui interviendront en
2014 nous parlons là d'une baisse
d'impôts pour trois millions sept cent
mille ménages mais c'est beaucoup quand
même c'est beaucoup ben c'est
pratiquement 20% de ceux qui payent de
ceux qui payent l'impôt en france
l'impôt sur le revenu notamment et en
pas la moitié de ces trois millions sept
cent mille seront sortis de lire pp donc
pour eux c'est effectivement une
excellente nouvelle alors comment ça
sera financée bande a eu la réponse ce
matin en lités parce que vous avez
appris ce matin en lisant le quotidien
les échos que jamais il ya eu autant de
gens qui ont payé l'is f et
l'augmentation de lits sflc 640 millions
d'euros par rapport à l'année dernière
dont voilà 640 millions d'euros qui
rentrent dans les caisses de manière
subreptice si vous ajoutez à cela le
fait je viens si vous ajoutez à ça le
fait de lait des expatriés fiscaux qui
vont rentrer et qui vont apporter un
milliard supplémentaire vous avez c'est
les plus riches
donc on peut même donner les proportions
qui ne sont quand même pas négligeable
parce que vous avez en gros les gens qui
paient ce fc 2 % des contribuables 2 %
des contribuables vont donc payer la
moitié de la baisse d'impôt de 20 % des
contribuables alors tout à l'heure sur
l'europe disait il faut qu'on
reconstruise un projet de gauche aidé à
dire est ce que votre reconstruction
d'un projet de golf c'est justement de
faire payer encore plus ces gens là
parce que c'est ça ça on fait partie oui
parce que je pense que les les
rendements annoncés de l'impôt sur la
fortune montre qu'au moment où beaucoup
de gens souffrent durement dans le pays
il ya quand même une petite
une toute petite partie de la population
c'est vrai en france comme au plan
international qui continue de s'enrichir
de manière considérable mais surtout
nous le coeur de la réforme fiscale
concernant les ménages que nous voulons
construire c'est qu'il faut un impôt
beaucoup plus progressif il faut 1 1 co
qui lui départ jusqu'à l'arrivée
jusqu'aux plus hautes tranches en europe
deviennent réellement progressif et on a
aujourd'hui un impôt qui va jusqu'à des
tranches de 2 45% et puis ensuite hop on
saute directement soit à l'impôt sur la
fortune soit à ce qu'il est resté de la
tronche sur les plus un million un
million de revenus en vérité on pourrait
très bien avoir un impôt qui continue
avec des tranches progressives de
manière à avoir davantage de justice
dans le système et on en est aujourd'hui
très très très très loin alors ça vous
fait une crasse chaque convient souffre
et une tranche à nos biens dans 15 à 45%
vous allez un entrepôt le revenu hier
mais on peut passer à des tronches à
55 à 60 elles ont déjà elles ont déjà
existé on a on a on a nous déposer des
propositions parlementaires avec un
système entre 12 et 14 tranche alors
qu'aujourd'hui on en a sept je me rends
en scène moi je suis pas et je suis pas
certain du chiffre donc il faut et vous
aller le vérifier mais donc on peut
avoir un impôt qui qui organise la vente
âge la progressivité c'était même le
sens parce que on a un système fiscal on
a un système fiscal il faut quand même
le dire qui marche complètement sur la
tête puisque l'essentiel des recettes
fiscales qui pèsent sur les ménages ne
sont pas l'imposition sur le revenu mais
sont les impôts indirects les taxes et
singulièrement la tva on oublie de dire
qu'on a le gouvernement oublie de dire
qu'il a augmenté la tva au moins de
janvier le
silence est l'impôt le plus injuste et
c'est celui qui rapporte
justice sociale donc il faut il faut il
faut il faut effectivement faire
diminuer les impôts directs les plus
injustes ce qui frappe le plus la
consommation des ménages et en
reconstruire un système fiscal il
s'intéressa l'instant michael vous
apercevez qu'à 14 milliards de recettes
fiscales attendues qui ne sont pas venus
c'est à dire qu'on arrive à un système
d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui où quelque
part pour reprendre la théorie de la
faire donc on peut critiquer un peu
l'impôt tuent l'impôt c'est-à-dire que
vous avez 14 milliards d'euros manquants
dans les caisses oui bon guiliano mise à
niveau mais il ya d'autres non mais il
ya d'autres il ya tout un autre pan du
problème donc on entre on ne parle pas
là et qu'on ne traite pas c'est qu'il ya
un problème
général général de l'efficacité de la
fiscalité sur les entreprises c'est à
dire que on a on a un système d'impôt
qui n'est pas incitatif de mon point de
vue à la création de richesses et on
continue de nous dire que la seule
manière d'encourager la création de
richesse c'est en fait la
défiscalisation des entreprises c'est
l'augmentation des exonérations de
cotisations sociales c'est ce que on
appelle la compétitivité par la baisse
du coût du travail et nous nous pensons
que ce qui fait défaut dans le système
de création de richesse c'est
l'insuffisance d'investissements
c'est l'insuffisance de coopération et
de partage sur les grands coups
d'investissements donc il faudrait aussi
repenser tout ça on pourrait mieux
davantage mais surtout mieux créer de
richesses et les richesses et ensuite
les redistribuer diffère ce très court
très simple est-ce que vous voterez le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui arrivera au sénat
non nous avons dit clairement que nous
ne voterons pas parce que nous nous
opposons à sa trajectoire d'ensemble ça
ne nous empêchera pas comme nous le
faisons toujours de mener une bataille
était d'amendements serré nous l'avons
dit tout à l'heure nous pouvons
converger il y a dans les propositions
des députés frondeurs des choses qui par
exemple permettraient sans même toucher
à l'équilibré du projet que nous nous
contestons mais du projet gouvernemental
de commandes de dégeler le augmentation
des allocations familiales des pensions
d'invalidité c'est des mesures que nous
votre projet explosif la réforme
ferroviaire merci beaucoup jean-louis la
hausse il va y avoir beaucoup de choses
à expliquer la réforme ferroviaire qui
devrait être débattu à partir la semaine
prochaine à l'assemblée nationale en
attendant il ya des grèves partout en
france et c'est évidemment les usagers
qui traquent on voit cinq fleurs
sauvages
manifestement les efforts du
gouvernement n'auront pas suffi à
désamorcer le mécontentement des
cheminots la grève à la sncf a été
reconduite jeudi la cgt et sud rail les
deux syndicats à l'origine du mouvement
proteste contre la réforme ferroviaire
du gouvernement une réforme qui doit
être examiné en première lecture par les
députés à compter du 17 juin le
gouvernement veut réunir la sncf et
réseau ferré de france dans une seule et
même entité le but mettre un terme à
l'endettement de rff et de la sncf en
2025 elle devrait grimper à 50 9
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui la dette
qui veut la faire payer aux cheminots
avec la productivité avec le manque
d'investissement donc voilà c'est bien
nous qui veut la faire payer alors que
cette dette a les structures lls une
dette d'aménagement du territoire qui a
été fait quand on a mis en place la le
tout tgv mais pour le gouvernement la
réforme ferroviaire est nécessaire c'est
une réforme qui est capital pour
l'avenir du ferroviaire
le système ne fonctionne pas bien je
pense à la séparation entre la gestion
des infrastructures et
la mobilité le transport l'etrat même
son de cloche chez réseau ferré de
france aujourd'hui les français se
plaignent à juste titre que notre réseau
ferroviaire a vieilli que la régularité
c'est un peu dégradée le trafic a
beaucoup augmenté l'offre a moins
augmenté que le trafic nous avons
beaucoup de projets à conduire et nous
avons besoin d'une cohésion entre les
scènes cfr ffc ça l'objet de ce projet
de loi le secrétaire d'état aux
transports doit recevoir les syndicats
dans la soirée à la veille d'un deuxième
jour de grève dans le transport
ferroviaire
françois hollande sera redit a déclaré
qu'il faut savoir arrêter le mouvement
ce mouvement doit s'arrêter que répondez
vous aux jardins publics ce n'est pas la
déclaration du président de la
république n'est pas sérieuse quand
quand la moitié des des cheminots sont
en grève et quand il ya un mouvement qui
dure depuis sur lesquels ils alertent
depuis des semaines le rôle du président
de la république c'est de ces de parler
sur les questions qui sont posées par
les cheminots et pas de faire un rappel
à l'ordre donc si si on vous les
comprenez vous très bien très bien parce
que moi j'ai parlé j'ai parlé avec les
juges étaient dans leurs manifestations
nationales dont personne n'a parlé et le
22 mai dernier ils étaient vingt mille
dans les rues de paris donc avant de
faire la grève ils ont plusieurs fois
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé et comme
d'habitude personne ne les écoute et
puis quand ils se mettent en grève ont
dit oh la la qu'est ce qui se passe ça
fait un an qu'ils sont dans des
manifestations nationales et des
mouvements pour dire il ya un problème
c'est un grave problème
du tout au contraire les cheminots
défendent le développement d'un réseau
ferroviaire qui est indispensable au
pays est indispensable à beaucoup de
français pour aller travailler ou pour
se déplacer donc ils portent l'intérêt
national les cheminots en posant les
questions qu'il peut y pose trois
questions dont vient on vient de parler
dans notre reportage mais qui ne sont
pas résolues il ya un problème d'unicité
de la sncf on a coupé la sncf en
morceaux on l'a rassemble pas parce que
enfin holding comme on dit général mais
on maintient trois entités différentes
et et on empêche les trades les
cheminots de travailler ensemble et e10
nous nous voulons travailler ensemble
nous voulons que tous les cheminots
puissent travailler main dans la main
donc on ne résout pas ce problème on ne
résout pas le problème de la dette et on
a un énorme problème d'investissement et
on leur donne pas les moyens d'investir
dans en attendant
le mouvement s'est quand même radicalisé
à l'heure où l'on se parle le bac le bac
et la cia sait pas même le mouvement ne
s'est pas radicaliser y a moyen simple
d'ailleurs si tout le monde apaiser la
situation roman donc le bac il suffit
que le président de la république dit
nous reportons d'une semaine ou de 15
jours le le débat parlementaire qui doit
commencer mardi et on prend ce temps là
pour mettre tout le monde autour de la
autour de la table et négocier jusqu'au
bout qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui oblige
à avoir une négociation qui a duré trois
heures hier et puis ensuite circulez il
n'ya plus rien à voir la paix nous sera
public aujourd'hui de reporter ce débat
l'ancien second pourrait reporter le
débat s'il n'est pas reporté nous comme
parlementaire nous allons nous battre
dans l'hémicycle pour changer ce projet
et répondre aux questions ce très
sérieuse qui sont posées par les
cheminots mais effectivement on pourrait
donner du temps à la négociation on
aurait pu le faire avant mais puisqu'on
ne l'a pas fait de la grève donc s'ils
continuent la grève pour vous c'est
acceptable mais mais oui parce qu'il
pose des questions qui sont des
questions
sérieuses sur l'avenir quand il y à
l'accident de brétigny sur orge
tout le monde y un problème ça
fonctionne mal quand il y à la sphère
dont on a parlé entre la taille des
quais et la taille des rames tout le
monde y un problème de fonctionnement
quand vous discutez avec les cheminots
dans les mêmes gars on les empêche de
travailler ensemble parce qu'on veut
séparer les activités pourquoi pour
préparer l'entrée du privé et l'entrée
dans la concurrence donc eu 10 nous nous
voulons mieux travailler ce sont des
gens attachés à leur entreprise ils
veulent servir les français du mieux
possible sur le trophée rotation on a
l'impression que ce statut est un atout
chat intouchable pourquoi y aurait-il
des règles différentes pour eux mais de
quoi parle-t-on je veux dire le problème
c'est qu'il faut que l'entreprise
fonctionne mais vous savez on dit bah
alors il faudrait il faudrait conduire
des tgv jusqu'à quel âge jusqu'à 62 ans
67 ans donc avoir une règle qui fait que
déroulant par exemple arrête de conduire
des trains qui sophistiqué qui
deviennent de plus en plus rapide et
donc avec des problèmes de sécurité
nouveau et bien le les faire arrêter
leur travail de roullens plus tôt c'est
une aberration non c'est au contraire
une mesure de segmenter alors on parle
d'un autre mouvement celui des
intermittents du spectacle qui se sont
mis en grève aussi pour protester contre
la nouvelle convention
d'assurance-chômage proposé par le
gouvernement des menaces planent sur les
festivals de l'été alors pierre laurent
est ce que vous êtes aussi aux côtés des
intermittents vous comprenez leur combat
pour conserver un statut spécifique mais
oui je le comprends et j'ai même demandé
et je soutiens ce mouvement depuis le
premier jour je fais partie du comité de
suivi des parlementaires qui accompagne
ce mouvement et j'ai encore la semaine
dernière fait au de demander l'audition
au sénat
de mathieu grégoire qui a fait à la
demande du 5 du syndeac et le syndicat
des employeurs de spectacle un rapport
qui montre que les intermittents ont des
propositions qui sont pérennes qui sont
équilibrées et qui permettent de
financer de financer un système vidéo
tout simplement parce que le medef tout
pour une simple raison le medef veut
faire sauter le régime des intermittents
qui est un régime utile et il veut le
faire sauter pour des raisons
idéologiques pour dire on ne peut pas
faire un système équilibré de cette
manière là et parce que ce régime est en
quelque sorte un pour le medef un
mauvais exemple de la solidarité qu'il
faudra gérer l'intermittence et la
coagulation deux des grands mais
pourtant contre françois hollande là ça
commence à demain ce ne sont pas les
seconds j'entends ce sont des gens qui
font vivre le pays le dire sans et
d'ailleurs on m'a malheureusement
peut-être s'en apercevoir cet été s'il
gouvernement à gré la corse que nous ne
menons pas de ne pas lui faire ils font
vivre des régions entières les
intermittents il n'ya au kiel n'y a pas
de spectacle vivant il n'y a pas de
festival fait les cheminots les
cheminots rien vous même vous même et
moi même nous n'allons pas nous ne
circuleront pas ce sont les cheminots
donc ce ne sont pas des mécontents ce
sont des gens qui travaillent et qui
disent nous voulons mieux travailler
nous voulons bien travailler toujours
sur notre dos que ça doit se passer
pendant qu'il ya des gens qui
s'enrichissent et qui font prévaloir des
stratégies de rentabilité financière
insupportable et qui disent la richesse
nous la créo et bien nous avons quand
même notre mot à dire sur la manière
dont on utilise donc arrêtons de
renvoyer ces gens ces gens ne sont pas
des mécontents ce sont des gens qui
propose de pouvoir travailler mieux au
service de la population à passer au
jeudi pierre leroy par les logements
on va parler d'une oie celle de cécile
duflot détricotage ou pas le premier
ministre s'interroge au coeur des
spéculations la loi de cécile duflot
devenu un symbole pour les a dénoncés
pour les autres quand un calme et nous
explique tout seul
2 avril 2014 passation de pouvoir entre
l'ancienne et la nouvelle ministre du
logement et le symbole choisi par cécile
duflot n'est pas anodin alors parfois la
politique a besoin de symboles voilà
c'est plus qu'une passation de pouvoir
sylvia c'est une passation de témoin je
te confie ce bien précieux je n'ai pas
choisi la couleur qu'est la loi lui
depuis avril les mesures phares du
projet n'ont toujours pas fait l'objet
de décrets d'application toujours rien
sur l'encadrement des loyers dans 38
grandes villes ni sur la garantie
universelle des loyers l'autre mesure
phare de la loi allure face à cette
attente les professionnels de
l'immobilier veulent voir une reculade
du gouvernement est une application a
minima du texte de cécile duflot il n'en
fallait pas plus pour faire réagir le
gouvernement à la sortie du conseil des
ministres stéphane le foll dément tout
renoncement t il n'y a plus de 100
décret sur la loi allure donc le jeu
sans jeu de mots la lure laquelle tout
ça se met en place nécessite un peu de
temps les priorités sont claires lorsque
vous sous-entendez c'est qu'il y aurait
dans les décrets d'application une
remise en cause de ce qui a été voté non
par définition dans la foulée au
ministère du logement on martèle le même
message prochain test pour sylvia pinel
dans deux semaines avec de nouvelles
annonces en conseil des ministres
relance de la construction de logements
est mise en place de plusieurs dizaines
de mesures de simplification de la
législation
jusque là sur compliqué texte un peu
trop lourd faut-il revenir sur ce texte
ou pas il aurait fallu qu'il aurait
fallu l'améliorer dès le départ s'il ya
des renoncements il va plus rien rester
parce que déjà le projet a été
relativement limités par rapport à
l'ambition qui étaient affichés au
départ alors si en plus on renonce à
certaines de ces mesures on se demande
ce qui va rester dans le projet en fait
depuis le début il y a des d dès l'aube
il est laid des promoteurs immobiliers
de ceux qui profitent de la spéculation
immobilière qui sont contre toute mesure
qui les contraindrait or nous sommes
dans une situation alarmante dans la
manière dont en matière de logement
puisque nous construisons moins de
logements d'année en année alors que les
besoins sont énormes et que la crise du
logement section 12 mois de crise mais
oui la construction de logements est
pourquoi elle est en crise parce qu'on a
on a on a détricoté beaucoup des moyens
de financement du logement social parce
que aussi des élus notamment les élus de
droite dans leurs villes refusent
d'appliquer la loi sru qui les obligera
à construire du logement social et parce
que on a drainé toutes les encours les
incitations financières notamment des
niches fiscales vers des gens qui sont
plutôt des profiteurs de la spéculation
ou qui profitent de la pénurie pour
faire éloigner plutôt des gens qui sont
soucieux dans l'axé par ce texte pardon
des deux premiers de ne pas toucher à
cet expert jeudi de ne pas toucher à
toutes ces mesures aux quelques mesures
positives qui avait dans ce texte ou
alors on va avancer je vous présente à
commencer par deux photos on va
commencer par la première propose la
photo de jacques toubon c'est une
personnalité de droite ancien ministe
jacques chirac françois hollande a
proposé son nom pour devenir défenseur
des droits à gauche on grince des dents
et vous
écoutez le défenseur des droits était un
personnage qui a un rôle important dans
qu'un rôle important et moi je constate
que des gens qui ont des ddd des profils
politiques très différents ont parfois
ont parfois bien rempli cette fonction
et d'autres m'ont donc ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas le choix de la personnalité
qui qui me détermine
devra s'exprimer oui mais alors
effectivement alors après il peut y
avoir sûrement une meilleure proposition
de celle de jacques toubon mais ce que
je veux dire c'est papa c'est pas par un
sectarisme aveugle que je
il faut il faut il faut déjà savoir de
la manière dont il envisage de remplir
ou non cette fonction qui a été
malheureusement aussi elle aussi
rabougri avait il y avait des
dispositifs et aux vertus on vous
attendait mais oui j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'avis définitif sur ce sujet une autre
personnalité en vue cette semaine
edouard snowdon celui qui a révélé la
sphère planétaire des écoutes de la nsa
américaine la semaine dernière de
sénatrice centriste ont déposé une
proposition de résolution pour faire de
lui un citoyen d'honneur de la
république c'est une bonne chose pour
vous il ya une unanimité des
parlementaires sur ça les verts sont
pour je ne sais pas s'il ya unanimité en
tout cas en tout cas cet homme-là
a rendu un service au monde entier en
révélant un véritable scandale scandale
international et qui continue qui
continue et on peut dire que la france
quand même n'a pas beaucoup élevé la
voix pour protester ou l'un fait très
brièvement et d'une manière générale
d'ailleurs je trouve qu'on se laisse
beaucoup marcher sur les pieds par les
américains quand j'ai vu l'autre jour
obama a donné la leçon à françois
hollande sur la sphère de la manda bnp
paribas et le président de la république
l'écouté sagement je me dit
effectivement que la france devrait
parler un peu plus haut et fort et dans
la sphère de l'espionnage aussi donc si
on peut envoyer des signaux qui consiste
à dire eh bien oui nous nous en avons
assez nous laisser marcher sur les pieds
par les états unis qui pensent qu'ils
sont là pour régir le monde et qui
doivent et qui peuvent faire tout ce
qu'ils veulent au dessus des lois sans
que personne ne leur disent rien et bien
si on peut envoyer des signaux comme ça
moi j'y suis favorable à plus de
l'époque alors vous aimez le football
oui j'aime beaucoup
les
appareils du football de la coupe du
monde et du brésil le brésil a gagné
donc ça devrait aller beaucoup mieux et
pourtant cette coupe du monde s'est
ouvert sous un fronde et de grogne
sociale aux attaques ciment barbarie le
football et le brésil un sport une
passion et des tensions surtout depuis
des mois une partie des brésiliens vit
mal les 11 milliards d'euros investis
dans la préparation de cet événement
sportif planétaire à sao paulo la coupe
est pleine pour les opposants au mondial
ce sont les joueurs qui vont s'enrichir
pas nous les prostituées les hôtels tout
ce qui entoure la coupe va aussi faire
du chiffre pour eux ce sera très bon
mais pour nous pour nous non nous allons
continuer dans la misère comme toujours
une vague d'hostilité inédite dans
l'histoire du pays un sondage cette
semaine indiqué que 72 % des brésiliens
étaient mécontents de cette situation
je pense que les gens sont déçus à cause
des problèmes qui connaissent au niveau
social il n'y a pas une participation
massive pour cet événement de la coupe
augmentation de salaire amélioration des
conditions de travail la classe moyenne
de plus en plus importante profite de
l'événement pour se faire entendre cette
semaine la grève du métro de são paulo a
provoqué des embouteillages monstres les
trois aéroports de rio subissaient des
perturbations la présidente dilma
rousseff a même dû s'essayer cette
semaine à la métaphore footballistique
pour vanter les bienfaits du mondial
organisé une coupe du monde c'est comme
disputer un match en sueur et parfois
dans la souffrance avec droit aux
prolongations et au penalty mais le
résultat est là célébration finale
vallée fort alors que la compétition
vient juste de commencer une élimination
prématurée de l'équipe du brésil
plongerait un peu plus le pays dans la
crise et serait un mauvais point pour
dilma rousseff candidate à sa réélection
en octobre prochain ont maintenant que
le coup de sifflet élancée que le brésil
a gagné son premier match silence on
joue par la suite la grogne non il faut
il faut en parler je pense que ce qui se
passait bien à l'image du brésil
d'aujourd'hui je pense que les
brésiliens sont sont heureux
d'accueillir la coupe du monde et on
verra l'engouement populaire surtout si
les brésiliens ont continué leur
parcours sportif on verra l'engouement
populaire grandir parce que c'est un
pays profondément épris épris de
football
c'est la nation du football mais en même
temps c'est un pays qui est socialement
exigeant qui est engagée dans des
transformations avec un peuple qui se
développe grâce d'ailleurs au politique
conduite par le gouvernement qui a fait
reculer la pauvreté et il ya un profond
désir aussi de développement social dans
ce pays et
n'accepte pas effectivement un certain
nombre de règles qui sont maintenant
imposés par la fifa sur la manière de
d'organiser une coupe du monde et ils
contestent la présence de l'argent trop
grande dans une compétition et ils ont
bien raison mais c'est l'argent des
soupçons de corruption et ses fins le
gouvernement
quand vous écoutez bien les
manifestations et moi j'ai lu beaucoup
de reportages il met en cause les
groupes privés qui s'en sont mis plein
les poches mais la privatisation de la
construction elle est imposée par les
normes de la fifa donc il faudrait aussi
regarder du côté de la manière dont on
organise ces événements et pas seulement
la cour mais les jeux olympiques et
d'autres grands événements encore dans
la tête quand même mais croire aux
chances des bleus pour ce mondial mais
bien sûr il faut aussi il faut faire la
fête mais moi je suis pour la lutte
festive de toute façon au brésil mais
pas seulement d'ailleurs way j'essaye de
concilier long terme annoncent
l'ospedale
parce que c'est comme ça que j'aime
vivre donc ya pas de raison d'avoir la
lutte triste il faut aussi le mot de la
fin pour cette émission vertement merci
beaucoup bien laurent à la semaine
prochaine on se retrouve évidemment
prochaine vendredi prochain bonne
semaine à tous sa semaine à tous merci
de votre fidélité
à bientôt